[Music]
curiosity is the most powerful thing you
own imagination is a force that could
actually manifest the reality I came out
of that movie and I thought that it's
unbelievable how much you want to go
there and it's interesting how they have
created that feeling that pandora is
actually a place and a beautiful place
where you think you would like to be the
game should deliver on that promise it
should be the ultimate experience where
you actually go to Pandora and where you
can live an alternative life on the moon
we are working side by side with
Lightstorm to create a game based on the
world of Avatar with the power of
massive snowdrop game engine and the
team's passion and obsessive focus on
detail we know they're the right group
to bring the beauty and danger of
Pandora to life
the mesmerizing world that you want to
visit and see with your own eyes to now
be able to recreate that in a computer
game is a fantastic humbling experience
the excitement is enormous and it's it
fits very well with many of the things
we are interested in ecology
sustainability fighting for what you
believe in a lot of interesting values
that really resonate well with the team
our mission is always to make the best
games in the world in this case I think
we have a unique opportunity to do
something that is very very rare every
player gets to choose how they want to
experience this incredible universe
we're about to embark on an amazing
adventure the insane attention to detail
is one of the few things that made
Pandora feel so real when we're done
everybody will get to experience the
beautiful world of Pandora
you
you
you